what does crypto medicine look like
relative to Fiat medicine to make the
same analogy right the existing medical
system it assumes that
um a quick death is is bad and early
death is bad
but also that living forever is either
unrealistic or impossible or undesirable
that you should die with dignity or
something like that okay
so a little death is good that's the
existing medical system
whereas the concept of life extension
and you know David Sinclair and you know
what they call you call it health span
says rejects that fundamental premise
and it says actually the way to defeat
cancer is to defeat aging aging is
actually a program biomedical biological
process and we can we have results that
are showing stopping or even reversing
Aging in some ways and so now just like
uh just like with the with the other
thing you say a quick death is bad
and so is actually death itself right so
we actually want significant life
extension this is similar it's very it's
very similar to what uh you know the the
rejection of the the Fiat system right
the field system says a low inflation is
good Fiat medicine says a little death
is good
Bitcoin says actually no inflation just
get more valuable over time and crypto
medicine says actually let's you know
extend life this leads to all kinds of
new things where you start actually
thinking about all right how do I
maintain my health with
um you know Diagnostics how do I
um you know take control of my own
health the decentralization of medicine
all the stuff that I've been describing
sort of fits like longevity is
traditional medicine as crypto is to
traditional currency if we take those
assumptions separately so we take
cryptocurrency aside
is that to you obvious that this letting
go of this assumption
about death is that is that an obvious
thing is longevity
Obviously good versus for example the
The Devil's Advocate to that would be
what we want is to keep death
and maximize the quality of life up
until the end well like so that uh you
ride into the sunset or healthy somebody
who is listening to whole Pockets say
well balji just a few hours ago you were
saying this gerontocracy runs the U.S
and they're all old and they don't get
it blah blah now you're talking about
making people live forever so there's
never any new blood to watch about haha
what a contradiction right it's funny
that
you're so on point across all the topics
we and uh all the topics we covered and
the possible criticism I love it well
just trying to anticipate you know
something well done so
the I think the argument on that is so
long as you have a frontier it is okay
for someone to live long okay so long as
people can exit to a new thing number
one number two is in order for us to go
and you know colonize other planets and
so on you know if you do want to get to
Mars if you want to become you know Star
Trek and you know what have you
um
probably going to need to have
you know like you know just to survive a
long flight so to speak you know
multiple light year flight you're going
to need to have life extension so to
become a pioneering you know
Interstellar kind of thing I know that
like it's it's the kind of thing which
sounds like okay yeah and when we're on
the moon we're gonna need shovels you
know it's it sounds like
a
piling a fantasy on top of a fantasy in
that sense but it's also something where
if you're talking about the vector of
our civilization where are we going well
I actually do think it's either an arc
of primitivism or optimism transhumanism
either we are shutting down civilization
as degrowth it's you know Unabomber Etc
or it's the stars and escaping the prime
number maze it's like to me
it's obvious that we're going to if
we're to survive expand out into space
yes and it's obvious
that once we do we'll look back at
anyone which is currently most people
that didn't think of this future didn't
anticipate as future work towards his
future as as luddites like as people who
did totally didn't get it it would
become obvious if right now it's
impossible and then it will become
obvious yes it seems like yes longevity
in some form I mean there could be a lot
of arguments of the different forms
longevity could take but in some form of
longevity is almost a prerequisite for
the expansion out into the cosmos that's
right expansion of longevity there's
also like a way to bring it back to
Earth to an extent which is how our
societies used to be judged you may
remember people used to talk about life
expectancy as a as a big thing right
life expectancy is actually a very very
good metric why it's a ratio scale
variable you know there's like four
different class of variables statistics
let's talk about ratio scale is like
years or meters or kilograms okay then
you have interval scale where plus and
minus means something there's no
absolute zero then you have ordinal
where there's only ranks and plus and
minister of anything and then you have
categorical like uh the Yankees and the
the the Braves are categorical variables
they're just different but you all you
have is the comparator operator whether
you have a quality you don't have a rank
okay
so ratio scale data is the best because
you can compare it across space and time
if you have a skeleton that is
like you know two meters tall
that's from 3000 years ago you can
compare the height of people from many
many years ago different cultures and
times right whereas their currency is
much harder to Value that's not like a
ratio scale variable other things are
harder to Value across space and time
right so life expectancy is good because
as a ratio scale variable is a very
clear definition right like when someone
born and died those are actually
relatively clear
um
by the most other things aren't like
that you know you uh that's why murder
or you know death that you know it can
be scored it's unambiguous you know it's
done when it's done whereas when did
somebody get sick oh they were kind of
sick or they're sick today they were
sick of this hour the boundary
conditions many other kinds of things
are not like clear-cut like that right
and I should just briefly comment that
life expectancy does have this quirk
a dark Quirk that it uh when you just
crudely look at it is incorporates uh
child mortality or mortality yes at age
of one or age of five and
um maybe it's better and clearer to look
at mortality after after five or
whatever uh and that's still those
metrics still hold in interesting ways
and measure the progress of human
civilization in interesting ways yeah
that's right you actually want longevity
biomarkers a lot of people are working
on this there's a book called The
Picture of Dorian Gray right and the
concept is sell your soul to you know
ensure the picture rather than he will
age and fade right and uh so the concept
is that that thing on the wall just
reflects his age and you can see it okay
so there's a premise that's in bed in a
lot of Western culture that
to gain something you must lose if you
if you're Icarus and you try to fly then
you will you know you'll fly too high
and you'll melt your wings but guess
what we fly every day commercial air
flight right so the opposite of like the
Icarus or picture of durian gray kind of
thing is the movie Limitless which I
love because it's so nietzschean and so
unusual relative to the dystopian you
know Sci-Fi movies where there's a
without giving I mean the movie's kind
of old now but
um there's a drug in it that's a
neurotropic that boosts you know your
cognitive abilities and it's got side
effects but at the end he Engineers out
the side effects amazing just like you
know yeah their planes are crash and we
we land right okay so why'd I mention
the picture during great well there's
another aspect of it which is
longevity by marker the point is to kind
of estimate how many years of life you
have left by
um you know that that Q dot bio or into
Chrome or you take all these analyzes on
on somebody right one of the best
longevity biomarkers could be
um just your face right you image the
face and you can sort of tell oh
somebody looks like they've aged oh
someone looks younger et cetera Etc and
um this is actually data that you've got
on millions and millions of people where
you could probably start having AI
predict okay what is somebody's life
expectancy given their current face and
other kinds of things right because you
have their name your birthday you have
their you know did they passed away if
they've already they've already passed
away right and you have photos of them
through their life right so just Imaging
might give a reasonably good longevity
biomarker but then you can supplement
that with a lot of other variables
and now you can start benchmarking every
treatment by its change and how much
time you have left if that treatment
that intervention
boosts your estimated life expectancy by
five years
you can see that in the data you can get
feedback on whether your longevity is
being boosted or not okay
um and so what this does is just
fundamentally changes the assumptions of
the system now with that said
uh you know life extension may be the
kind of thing I'm not sure if it'll work
for Our Generation we may be too late it
may work for the next Generation
wouldn't that make you sad
well I've got something to the last
generation could be but I've got
something for you which is uh I call it
genomic reincarnation
okay this one you probably haven't heard
before I've tweeted about it okay so by
the way good uh
time to mention that your Twitter is one
of the greatest twitters of all time so
people should follow you well Alex
Friedman has one of the greatest
podcasts of all time you guys should
listen to The Lex Friedman podcast which
you may be doing right which you may be
doing right now yes yeah uh well thank
you so uh what was the term again sorry
genomic uh sir I call it genomic not
Resurrection but genomic reincarnation
okay so here's the concept you may be
aware that you can synthesize strands of
DNA okay
um there's sequencing of DNA which is
reading it and synthesizing DNA which is
like creating strands of DNA
uh what's interesting is you can
actually also do that at the full uh
chromosome level for bacterial
chromosomes remember that thing I was
saying earlier about the minimum life
form you know that Craig Venter made so
people have synthesized like entire
bacterial chromosomes and they work like
they can literally essentially print out
a living organism all right now when you
go uh from bacteria to eukaryotes which
are the the
kingdom of life that we're part of right
yeast are part of this Kingdom and so on
it becomes harder because the
chromosomes are more complicated
but folks are working on eukaryotic
chromosome synthesis and if you spot me
that sci-fi assumption that eventually
we'll be able to take your genome
sequence and just like we can synthesize
a bacterial chromosome we can synthesize
not just one eukaryotic chromosome but
your entire complement of chromosomes in
the lab right because you have you know
23 and you know 46 whatever you take the
pairs what you can do is potentially
print somebody out from disk
reincarnate them
insofar if your sequence determines you
and you can argue with this because
there's epigenetics and our stuff okay
but let's just say to first order your
DNA sequence is Lex you can sequence
that okay you can do full genome
sequencing and log that to a file then
here's the you know the karma part your
crypto community
where you've built up enough Karma among
them
if when you die your karma balance is
high enough
they will spend the money
to reincarnate the next Lex who can then
watch
everything that happened in your past
life
and you can tell them something
everything I described there I mean if
you spot me eukaryotic chromosome
synthesis
that's the only part that like you know
I think I think will be possible Right
folks are working on it I'm sure someone
multiple messages essentially a clone
it's like a clone right but it is
um it is you in a different time
you're in a different time but you don't
unfortunately have the memories well you
could probably watch the like the digest
of your life
and it would be pretty interesting right
I mean yeah the the you know that's
actually a process for psychology to
study if you create a blank mind what
would you need to show that mind to
align it very well
with the experiences with the
fundamental experiences that Define the
original version such that the resulting
clone would have similar Behavior
patterns worldviews perspectives
feelings all those kinds of things
potentially right including sadly enough
traumas and all that or what have you
right but basically just like in a very
simple version of it
you know by the time one is age 20 or 30
or something tell me your 20s you'll
sort of learn your own personal
operating system you're like oh
alcohol really doesn't agree with me or
something like that you just by trial
and error you know things that are
idiosyncratic to your own physiology
you're like oh you know I I'm totally
wrecked if I uh get seven hours of sleep
versus nine hours or whatever it is
right you people will have different
kinds of you know things like this that
manual can be given to your next self so
you can know don't do this do this don't
do this do this right to some extent
personal genomics already gives you some
of this where you're like oh I'm a
caffeine nun you know or a slow
metabolizer oh that explains X or Y you
know or I have a weird version of
alcohol dehydrogenous oh okay that
explains you know my alcohol tolerance
so you know this is part of the broader
category of what I call practical
Miracles right so it's longevity it's
genomic reincarnation it is restoring
sight and it is curing deafness with you
know the uh you know artificial eyes and
artificial ears it is
um the super soldier serum did I show
you that so like myostatino a tweet
about this basically X-Men are real so
here is a study from any gym from
several years ago okay uh whereas this
is like the mid-2000s
this was in
2004 okay so it's now 17 years later
it's probably this is almost certainly a
teenager by now so this kid
basically was just
totally built yeah okay extraordinarily
most like very muscular at a at a very
young age yes so the child's birth rate
was in the 75th percentile he appeared
extraordinarily muscular the protruding
muscles in his thighs motor and mental
development has been normal now at four
and a half years of age she continues to
have increased muscle ball constraint
and so essentially myostatic mutation
associated with gross muscle hypertrophy
in a child so this is like real life
X-Men okay and
um it has pictures of animals
yes this is coming called variant bio
that is looking at people who have
exceptional health related traits and it
is looking for essentially this kind of
thing but maybe more disease or or
whatever related right for example
people who have natural immunity to
covid understanding how that works
perhaps we can give other people
artificial immunity to covet right
um if you scroll up you see my kind of
tweet super soldier Serum is real where
it's like wild-type mouse and a
myostatin null
and look at the chest on that thing you
see the before and after wow okay this
is what's possible you know this could
be us but you're regulating
you know right you're not saying like
this could be SB play this could be us
but the FDA regulating right all this
okay oh yeah on steroids but it's not
that's the thing is well that's the
thing is people when people again you go
back to the Icarus thing they think oh
steroids well that's definitely going to
give you cancer screw up your hormones
etc etc and it could but you know what
like have we actually put in that much
effort into figuring out like the the
right way of doing testosterone
supplementation or the right way of
doing this uh obviously we managed to
put a lot of effort into marijuana
increasing the potency of it or what
have you could we put the effort into
these kinds of drugs right or these
kinds of compounds Maybe
I think that would actually be a really
good thing the thing about this is I
feel this is just a massively
underexplored area
um rather than people drinking caffeine
all the time that's like a very mild
enhancing drug okay uh nicotine is also
arguably kind of like that you know some
people have it even without the
cigarettes right
why can't we research this stuff one way
of thinking about it is you know Lance
Armstrong the the cyclist
yes he violated all the rules
um you know he shouldn't have won the
Tour de France or anything like that
but as chemists and I say this somewhat
tongue-in-cheek but also you know his
chemists are candidates for like the
Nobel Prize in chemistry
because they brought a man back from
like testicular cancer
to like winning Tour de France's against
a bunch of guys who probably you know a
bunch of them are also Juiced or
whatever right
whatever it was done there take it out
of the competition framework there's a
lot of testicular cancer patients or
cancer patients period who would want
some of that
and we should take that seriously we
should take that Pursuit really really
really seriously Yes except again just
like the thermo stuff all this
pathologized oh it's a battleco scandal
oh it says oh my God you know and yes of
course within the context of that game
they're cheating when the context of
life you want to be cheating death
right so
um it's just a kind of a reframe on what
is good right and it is just taking away
these assumptions that mild inflation is
good or mild death is good and going
towards Transcendence so that gets me
done with the giant FDA biomedical et
cetera Etc longevity yeah that's
beautifully beautifully done